what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today look at that we got two
reactions this week for brooklyn
nine-nine impromptu decision can't
promise this is gonna be a regular thing
but looking over the video manager it
was like okay we've been fine with the
claims lately so let's try it this week
so can't promise this is going to be
consistent we just happen to have a slot
open right now
yep that's the intro subscribe click
that bell hit that like button check us
out on patreon for the full length watch
along as we cover a whole bunch of other
shows over there as well as you guys
probably already know
thank you to pratham janelle for adding
these down let's do it
[Music]
whoa what's with the cast i sprained my
wrist oh no what happened don't worry
about it i'm fine yeah geez amy back off
chief all right huddle up everybody
bring it in bring it
so he wouldn't say what happened which
can only mean one thing he's in a fight
club no
i tripped over an uneven sidewalk i did
not think it was relevant to your jobs
the jobs which you should all be doing
right now
get to work
lies
do you want to know how i actually hurt
my wrist
i was hula-hooping oh my god i've
mastered all the moves
the pizza toss
[Laughter]
why are you telling me this
yeah because no one
will ever believe that
[Laughter]
waiting for assault son of a [ __ ]
oh that is true satisfaction and you
can't use it what has three thumbs and
just made another arrest this guy
this took a lot of hard work and a lot
of late nights take the weekend off
peralta thank you you know actually mike
i'm severely sleep deprived and i'm way
behind on laundry good work oh
that's nice
what's going on what's with the bag are
you going on a cruise with your mom in
1913. this is a very stylish bag no
teddy and i are going to the berkshires
for the weekend teddy just a romantic
getaway wow that's great i know we're
kind of taking things to the next level
what are you doing this weekend
work shirts working whole weekend
fighting crime
can i call you back bye uh-oh what are
you doing in here talking to vivian
thing is it's so hard to talk at work
because there's no privacy the roof is
freezing
let me work on it
hands up cop hey no no no no no it's
teddy your boyfriend oh boyfriend yeah
you release my arm oh yeah sorry
oh i just wanted to see you before we
left for the weekend uh
what's this weekend we rented a cabin in
the berkshires we're taking a couple's
cooking class and there's this great
antiques fair sounds like you two have a
wonderful lesbian vacation plan
[Laughter]
because that is when you promised holt
you'd help with this community outreach
meeting that's this weekend i totally
forgot how did i let the captain talk me
into that excuse me everyone would one
of you be willing to
i'll do it i volunteer all my time
[Laughter]
we can reschedule or you could just lie
to captain hall
i'm not gonna lie i'll just tell the
captain i made a mistake and he'll
understand okay but if you do lie you
can't go wrong with dental emergency or
death of a triplet now that one you can
use twice
good news sergeant i figured out what
we're gonna work on this weekend i'm
working on spending time with my family
i thought you were taking a weekend off
no i decided to spend the weekend taking
things to the next level
work wise i found a cold case of ours
that everyone foolishly said was
unsolvable case 52 abx-32qj
case 52
abx-32qj is unsolvable or maybe case 52
abx-32qj is waiting for someone to
de-unsolve it what's case 52 abx-32qj
case 52
guy nate dexter was murdered in a boat
explosion no witnesses no leads minimal
evidence we're better detectives now
we're smarter computers are faster no
more blockbuster drones
[Laughter]
convincing oh he's standing up i've
always wanted to solve that case and
think about how good it would feel to
finally do it what's the best moment of
your life my wedding day tied with the
day my babies were born compared to this
those memories will be garbage
[Laughter]
they blew up his boat with him still on
it and left no evidence except this one
charred finger and nate's melted torso
start at the last place that dexter was
seen before he went to the marina his
apartment i'm telling you sarge i got a
good feeling about this
oh
no
it appears his building was torn down
hey
we need to tell charles about babylon he
needs a private place to talk to vivian
what no babylon's our secret place it's
the best thing in my life and i have a
very full life do you know i know papa
john
the papa john
oh no
he's incapable of keeping a secret
i shouldn't tell you this but we're
throwing you a surprise party later
all right convict what do you know about
the murder of nate dexter
look i'll tell you the same thing i told
you eight years ago the best french
toast i ever ate was with mayor
linsley's dog
he's very old he's lost his mind
we're making progress hello captain my
old friend i've come to talk with you
again
santiago can i help you i need to speak
with you about this weekend ah yes i'm
so happy you'll be there to oversee the
audio visual presentation the last time
did not
go well the next chart shows the drop in
the crime rate over the last month
i just erased
everything
but i think i'm gonna be unable to help
out tomorrow why's that i'm getting my
wisdom teeth pulled i've been in pain
for days all right no idea you were
living like this no one knows
[Laughter]
will you just tell me where we're going
guys
guys
welcome to babylon
it's our secret bathroom
wow
but you have to promise not to tell
anyone about this
i pinky promise not good enough blood
packs no
yeah
you know anything about the murder of
nate dexter i can't be sure
but i think dexter owed money to a guy
named sam bunsen
first lead in eight years
you were right oh
beat down boulevard it's a tough fifth
street in town
[Laughter]
santiago how are your teeth feeling
still hurts but i can make it till
tomorrow well if you're in this much
pain i don't think you should wait my
brother-in-law is one of the top oral
surgeons in the quint state area that's
two better than the tri-state area he's
agreed to see you tonight at six as a
personal favorite of me and kevin wow
thank you but
that's not gonna work because of the
anesthesia and driving myself home
teddy can take me nonsense i'll drive
you to and from the dentist office
myself oh god no
no sign of sam bunsen in the federal
database you got anything bad news i
only found his wife and she hasn't heard
from him in eight years hmm i bet mrs
bunsen is lying she knows where her
husband is she says she's willing to
take a lie detector test well then let's
bust out the polygraph
lie detector truth or dare no boy last
time you did that you ended up telling
everyone you had a crush on the teapot
for beauty and the beast it's the way
they chew her
[Music]
he meant pretty hot all right pretty boy
where is it where's what the secret
bathroom series what
beth and where okay cap i'll be right
there don't lie to us no
at 11 18 a.m rosa told you to follow her
and you guys left together
he returned to 11 31 smelling of
lavender
you've been drinking chamomile tea all
day long and haven't been to the men's
room once since when are you two so into
being good detectives since it came to
secret bathrooms tell us where it is oh
god
[Laughter]
let's do it again jake what's going on
with you she passed a chest like five
times or maybe
she's in cahoots with him hmm
are you cahooting
damn it's over man no
the visual examination doesn't show much
inflammation but these x-rays should be
more telling don't stop santiago
oh
i forgot i promised to help you and i
made plans to go to the berkshires with
my boyfriend oh
wait
you lied to me to get out of work
yes
i may be a liar but i've got great teeth
and no one can take that from me have
you heard of over-brushing oh no your
aggressive technique has stripped away
the protective enamel and much of your
gum you have seven cavities
oh
oh wow
i feel like you deserve this
[Laughter]
insta karma
no what yep this is happening look i'm
sorry you let me into your special place
ew i messed up
i don't know why you want to spend the
entire weekend at work but i'm going
home to my family see you tomorrow jake
fine abandon me i don't want you here
anyway that's a lie come on
i would love to do a live adventure test
let's do one live on the channel holy
moses what happened to you i have not
slept and since i last saw you many
hours i rewatched the interrogation and
get this
sophia wasn't lying about anything but
she does know something way better come
with me
[Laughter]
allow me to introduce to you our murder
victim the not dead
nate dexter
what the hell is going on
right
she hadn't seen her husband in eight
years but she was positive there's no
way that he killed dexter that's when it
occurred to me
no one killed him
hey nate just talking about how you're
alive
yeah i'm alive but whose melted torso
did we find sophia's husband yes
sophia and dexter were having an affair
husband found out nate killed him
now i'm telling my friend about how you
killed that guy it was for love
also you remember that severed finger
check this out hey nate show us your
hands please oh
right
cut it off himself how screwed up is
that
anyway
and unsolvable case
solved
i actually feel really happy for it
damn good work
you want your bathroom back fine i want
your chair mine smells like my butt ew
fine and we want your coyote blanket
it's not a coyote is a wolf learn your
animals idiot i told you she wasn't
serious let's go scully
fine
i can't believe you gave up wolfie it
was worth it plus i'm done with wolves
now i'm into angry unicorns
if i was a unicorn i'd never be angry
[Laughter]
i've had a dental thing but you're such
a good brusher i know
turns out that was my undoing classic
yeah i hate him
oh yeah hey man how are you great solve
we hate him we hate him
you hate him too copper
everyone raise your glasses to the
amazing jake peralta today he did the
impossible he closed case 52 abx-32qj
is that right
you're amazing
for the past two days you've been
telling me how amazing it was gonna be
to solve this case
this does not look amazing i thought i'd
be more psyched too
maybe i just need a cooler case no that
is not gonna work
you set the precinct record you weren't
happy you solved an unsolvable case you
won't have no case is gonna make you
happy
something's bothering you
and whatever it is you got to deal with
it
yeah well maybe i can't deal with it
right now or kill teddy
yes
oh
that's a tough one but solving more
cases isn't gonna make you feel any
better having a drink with a friend
might though thank you but i don't think
another drink is gonna help
i think having a lot more drinks might
help
there he is
so
amy
all right let's talk about it
teddy is just the worst god he was just
he ruined this episode just like he
shows up and you just want to curb
stomping yeah you know yeah you just
want to like tase him in places people
shouldn't be tased and like hit him with
a bag full of frozen oranges so you
don't leave a bruise hate that guy yeah
man where does he get off
being being teddy all the time
stepping in on peralta's turf
a good analogy women are turf that's
right property in fact
objects whoa whoa be careful you don't
want to go too far whoa so you don't
want to start sounding like see me with
you
you know listen all right different
genders are just briefs
different levels of ability
i played football with a girl once
and through that experience i have
decided all women must play this way
some people say we don't talk about
enough
variety of things we just inserted into
random random videos look at that look
at that woke joke
um book jokes yeah
let's uh i don't really we need
verification that's him first before i
can form an opinion
of
simulu's actions on reddit
gotta confirm his username
the most random news could be another
canadian asian actor indeed
there's a lot of them out there very
common yeah you know
it's a growing market in hollywood's
canadian asian actors
um that's you should have been canadian
you got the wrong white white we're just
here to make it we want a heritage
guys listen
other than cemu liu uh
what do you think of the episode i was
delighted throughout this episode i
enjoyed every storyline
much like most of these episodes
but uh it was yeah i thought this one
was sharp
the bathroom reminds me of like this one
time when john used the bathroom when
the water was off and i was like you
sick bastard
only i'm allowed to use the bathroom
when the water's off you go drive down
to
starbucks ask them to take a poop there
yeah
i didn't poop that time look how
everyone just assumed you were in there
for a while it's a lot easier i wasn't
in there that long i don't know maybe i
was looking at the phone suffice it to
say i just sit down and pee
drop your trousers and then pee and then
stand and pitch
i need two hands to do all the closing
up i you don't need two hands but
usually you're using two hands to close
up shop after taking a tank so you know
you know hitchcock either way
they were they they did real detective
work i really love how that is the one
thing they took seriously motivated they
actually played believable intimidating
cops for a hot minute
and that was actually a really funny bit
surprised how how much of a past rose it
gave him i would i still feel like even
though really gave him a pass even
though boyle is uh
you know saved her life and everything i
still feel like rosa
an episode ago would have
been like you blew it i trusted you and
you blew it yeah and i'm setting you
down and i'm going to punch you or
something you know
but uh a secret bathroom though i wonder
though i wonder if that is a sign of a
character turn or something or if she's
just you know taking more of a shine to
boil
i feel like this could be signifying you
know the next coming conflict for the
impending marriage
i don't get
why women's bathrooms are generally way
nicer than men's
hmm
yeah let me rephrase i get it because
men are disgusting and gross
but we would appreciate the effort but i
don't i've never treated a bathroom the
way
it
looks
you've never walked in and just pissed
all over this yeah just just in the
general direction of a toilet just carve
stuff in no walls
yeah
not flush
and just like spool like tons of toilet
paper more than you know will be able to
go down into the bowl hey i hate it i
don't i don't i don't get it i don't
understand
never have never will i find it obscene
repulsive yeah
and uh yeah
you know what they don't tell you though
is i've heard from
several women
credible women
that women's rooms are also
quite disgusting once you get past the
loungy accoutrements that they put at
the front
oh yeah they take bigger dumps and all
that's right that's the secret that's
why this is how they stay
here it's the battle [ __ ] scene from
harold and kumar
every women's review going
but it would be nice you know to get
like a love seed in the men's room why
not maybe a nice painting i hate that it
smells awful why would you want i've
never seen it i've never been drawn to
the idea of just like keep it clean
some candles in there you've never been
drawn to the idea of keeping it clean
i've never been drawn to the idea of
like a
couch
yeah just like lounging in the bathroom
like who wants that yeah yeah
someone just goes in don't need to take
a [ __ ] don't worry i'm just gonna sit on
this couch
i'm just gonna listen
i'll read my magazines
are you trying to discreetly poop next
to me that's disgusting i'm gonna listen
to hear who is really wishing i couldn't
hear them right now
yeah that's disturbing that is
disturbing
and then on the other side of the
episode you got the lie
caught in the lie
would lie oh yeah a b wisdom teeth
i know you gotta learn how to lie better
yeah
yeah in constant line
check out this one okay
i'll see if it fools me all right
i have a really
small
penis no you don't i know i've seen it i
can't i can't i can't i cannot i don't
believe in you commit to that don't
worry why would you do it it is massive
that's why whenever i go to the bathroom
there's just piss everywhere
i can't control it if i wanted to
i gotta use two hairs pressure is just
too much everywhere
oh that's good that means your prostate
works really well
hold seem really hurt he did
this this episode even when he agreed in
the end he was like
it's like somber
yeah this episode had ending notes with
characters where i'm like i feel like
there's more to that well you gotta have
a cliffhanger for your big finale yeah
will holt still be mad i actually felt
really happy they solved the case
because i know something about setting
it up as this unsolvable case over the
last eight years is
i felt like oh this is a good reward
well and because of like his odd
behavior in like going so gung-ho about
it too part of me was like oh maybe it's
going to be one of those episodes where
they don't solve the case but they
learned something valuable but i i like
that choice of like he does it's awesome
he doesn't get like the emotional
benefits he was looking for but yeah
like when they actually do solve the
case and it's a little different than
you'd expected like the outcome actually
felt like i was witnessing the
conclusion
to a mystery i'd spent a lot more time
on the details
or something i i like uh i i think my
favorite pairing with peralta on in
terms of
investigation cases is generally terry
because
terry
he has like both of the qualities of
his dynamic with that that like when
it's holds my god that sound outside
i swear to god this is like a home depot
yeah man
there's a bunch of workers out front
looking for something to do people poke
their heads out they're like hey can you
leaf blow this
it just doesn't stop
what is this
electric saw you have now working on
wood didn't stop doing foliage in your
building must grow at an alarming rate
because they're always like sawing stuff
and leaf blowing stuff and shutting the
water down and lighting something on
fire and it like
doesn't stop
um
so yeah the uh
we were talking about we were talking
about um
if i forget i mean thank god harry and
terry and peralta being your favorite
people yes
because terry has this um
he carries both qualities of true
friendship with peralta
true care and like the the way he treats
him showcases that
really truly recognizes the skilled and
great detective that he is but he also
knows how to bring in those like fun
like idiosyncrasies
i think i'm using that word right yes
hey google
what does idiosyncrasies mean it's too
far in the room
it's okay believe in yourself you did it
you did it yeah it's a good use of the
word
yeah you know it's not
mercurial in the way his manners are
with the photo
i suppose not
i suppose terry would not be easier to
use the word mercurial it's easier to
use that word when someone's being
material
like to try to apply it when someone's
not inside of experience it's like the
federal definition of pornography it's
hard to describe but you know when you
see it
uh
so but but he also knows how to treat
him like
um
he also knows how to react to him in
like the ways when peralta's being an
idiot
you know so he has like both of those
qualities i think are really on display
of
the the trusting of fate faith-based
partner
not like god based but you know faith in
him partner belief in him and then also
uh the way to play off of him when he's
being a dumbass yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
so yeah so i love their dynamic like a
lot it's like it probably has a
different dynamic with anyone he's
paired up with but i think my favorite
is him and terry
yeah i think yeah cause like terry is is
his superior but he's not the boss and i
feel like that's a big part of his
because you know it's like they still
have that chummy sort of like yeah we're
just out on our own and the you know
captain's not here but at the same time
terry is gonna whip him into shape yeah
i agree i love their dynamic and it's
fun like i i i enjoyed seeing charles
cornered between uh rosa and uh uh gina
as well just i don't know like yeah the
way everybody all the supporting
characters around him are just like in
in such ways that he thinks they're
going to beat him up or something like
that like
that's quite amusing
all right guys well there you go two
episodes of brooklyn nine-nine this week
to satisfy those 20 consistent comments
always
you better comment double this time it's
easy to get a few and then go everyone
wants that yes
everybody every comment's the only
comment check out the last four uploads
from thursday to friday yeah
see how we are food
everybody wants view counts are so up oh
boy
somebody wanted it somebody wanted it if
you said it and it looked like everyone
did just for you generally not an
exclusive video that we made exactly for
you so i hope you like it
all right guys
we'll see you soon thank you for being
here
[Music]